[Music]
the religion of the ethical spirit
is however its elevation above its real
world the withdrawal from its truth into
the pure
knowledge of itself since the ethical
nation lives in immediate unity with its
substance and lacks the principle of the
pure
individuality of self-consciousness the
complete form
of its religion first appears as
divorced
from its existential shape for the
reality of the ethical substance
rests partly on its passive
unchangeableness
as contrasted with the absolute movement
of self-consciousness
and consequently on the fact that this
self-consciousness has not yet withdrawn
into itself
from its contented acceptance of custom
and its firm
trust therein partly too
on its organization into a multiplicity
of rights and duties
as also on its distribution into the
spheres of the various classes and their
particular activities which cooperate to
form the whole
and hence on the fact that the
individual is content
with a limitation of his existence and
has not yet grasped the unrestricted
thought of his free self
but that tranquil immediate trust in the
substance turns
back into trust into one in oneself and
into the certainty of oneself
and the multiplicity of rights and
duties like the restricted activity
is the same dialectical movement of the
ethical sphere
as the multiplicity of things and their
specific
natures a movement which finds its rest
and stability only in the simplicity of
the spirit that is certain of itself
the consummation of the ethical sphere
in free self-consciousness and the fate
of the ethical world
are therefore the individuality that has
withdrawn into
itself the absolute levity of the
ethical spirit which has dissolved
within itself all the firmly established
distinctions of its stable existence
and the spheres of its organically
ordered world and
being perfectly sure of itself has
attained to unrestrained joyfulness
and the freest enjoyment of itself
this simple certainty of spirit within
itself
has a two-fold meaning it is a serene
stable existence and settled truth and
also absolute unrest in the passing away
of the ethical order
but it changes round into the latter for
the truth of the ethical spirit is
in the first instance still only this
substantial essence and trust in it
in which the self does not know itself
as a free individuality
and which therefore in this inwardness
or in the liberation of the self
perishes since then its trust is broken
and the substance of the nation bruised
spirit which hitherto mediated the
unstable extremes
has now stepped forth as an extreme that
of self-consciousness grasping itself as
essence
this is spirit inwardly sure of itself
which mourns over the loss of its world
and now out of the purity of self
creates its own
essence which is raised above the real
world
paragraph 701 is a pretty long
and dense paragraph there's a lot going
on in this hegel actually uses the word
dialectic
at one point and i think we can say that
that's what's happening
throughout this entire paragraph a lot
of the features
of the hegelian dialectic and by that i
mean the real hegelian dialectic
not that silly nonsense that people turn
into memes with
you know thesis antithesis synthesis
this is actually this is the real
dialectic right here
that we're getting to see and it's it's
uh
touching on something that's really at
the heart of the
hegelian project overall and
in the phenomenology the ethical
substance
the entirety of the phenomenology
you could say is not just like a record
of
where spirit has been and you know sort
of like a mausoleum or a museum
with things that we are now you know
allowed to see
exhibits of right it's supposed to be
practical there's
a development that we are going along
with in part so we can identify what's
what's like this in the world
for us now this is about ancient greek
religion that is the free people that
hegel has in mind here and i i guess you
could also say by extension
you know the larger greek influenced
world of the romans as well
and you know we might extend this to
the entire sphere of the
mediterranean and the middle east that
is is connected with greek culture
you know all the way to india
and mixing in other things as well
although hegel doesn't have
you know a really great conception of
this as
as we do today he's working with you
could say
less uh less ethnographic
studies less history less things like
that and he's got to put it together and
he is very centered on
the greeks he talks here about the
religion
of the ethical spirit what is the
religion of the ethical spirit what
we've seen developed in the last two
paragraphs where we've gone from the
worker and you know statuary or
architecture
stuff like that to this belonging to
a people and not just any people not
just replicating
restless antagonistic you know [ __ ]
fighting each other but a sphere of
freedom
this is really quite central for
hegel the entire phenomenology this is
becomes much more clear
in the reason and spirit and religion
and absolute knowing section is oriented
towards
towards freedom and that is what hegel
thinks history
is a working out of i mean there's other
themes involved as well it's not just
freedom all the time but that's that's
quite central so he says
the religion of the the ethical spirit
is its
elevation above now he doesn't say
the real world right and
what he's talking about there what's
being translated as a real world
virtually
actuality reality it's
reality which may not be the same as
reality per se
but it a reality that it itself
has to deal with and project out there
onto things
so he says it's an elevation above its
real world the withdrawal from its truth
into the pure knowledge of itself
and this is the starting point of the
paragraph this is really what is
happening
throughout the entire paragraph and this
rather abstract formulation
that we you know we've seen hegel say
stuff like this all the time pure
knowledge of itself right
the pure knowledge of itself is not
going to turn out to be quite so pure
and
it's not going to be solely of itself
but it is going to be
you know spirit is centered upon itself
in making sense out of itself in
religion
so he goes on and he says the ethical
nation
lives in immediate unity with its
substance
right what does that mean
immediate unmediated right the
ethical uh substance is what the the
nation is living
in continuity with that they are not
exactly identical but they are certainly
we could say overlapping at multiple
points right the ethical nation
lives in its own ongoing immediate
unmediated unity and then here he says
and lacks the principle of the pure
individuality
of self-consciousness here we've got to
be a little bit
careful it hegel doesn't say
just that it lacks the principle of the
pure individuality of self-consciousness
he actually in the german says that the
the ethical nation doesn't have this
within it so yes it does technically
lack it but it's going to have it
brought back
within it and that's going to transform
it
as individuality becomes something
really central here so something driving
the you might say the
the tool the vehicle of spirit
so he goes on and he says because these
are the case the ethical nation is in
immediate unity lacks this principle the
complete form
of its religion first appears as
divorced
from its existential shape it's bestian
right
how it is in there so its complete form
of religion appears
as separated from this and he goes on
and says the reality of the ethical
substance so the reality of the vehicle
kite of this ethical substance rests and
here he goes partly on this
partly on this so we've got to look at
both sides
of this partly or on the one hand on the
other hand
how do we how do we unpack that
so we have what we can call passive
unchangeableness
right restful you know
and then we have the organization and
and hegel actually uses the term
organization here
as we've seen him do in the previous
paragraphs at different points and
throughout the phenomenology he'll use
latinate
forms rather than german forms every
once in a while
the organization into multiplicity field
height
right differentiation um
a i mean you could say multiplicity
unfolding right if you want to play on
that idea
so both of these are are important right
both of these are what the ethical
substance
in its vehicle kite in its reality
in its being in the world rests upon
he says it rests partly on its passable
passive unchangeableness as contrasted
with the absolute movement of
self-consciousness right so
there's there's a there's a already a
differentiation taking place
here and then he goes on and he says
consequently on the fact that this
self-consciousness
has not yet withdrawn into itself from
its contented
acceptance of custom and it's fear it's
firm trust therein now what is custom
zita
right so we're playing off of this
factor that we've already talked about
um ethical you know zit lika
is coming from zida which you know
i'm going to go on a little bit of a
digression here people always want to
contrast morality
and ethics and they're you know one is
coming from latin terms one is coming
from greek terms
uh mores are the same thing as ethe
you know the customs the norms right
one is latin one is greek and so what
we're talking about here
is not some sort of ethics like what we
get in a textbook where we say
well there are three main kinds of
ethics there's consequentialist ethics
best represented by utilitarianism
there's deontological ethics which is
best represented by emanuel kant or
maybe you know uh wd ross and and robert
audi's intuitionism
and then there's virtue ethics and we're
not quite sure where to put that and
then we've also got feminist i think
okay that's that's nice that that's all
real stuff
but that's not what hegel means here he
doesn't mean
people whipping out a a book and
consulting
i mean they may have it like stored away
in their head with a bunch of you know
injunctions but
it's not some systematized
based on principles that should be
immediately
in evident to all rational beings kind
of
ethics that we're used to right this is
uh
kind of commonsensical every day
learning from your your parents and your
predecessors and
your educators and whoever else
sometimes in the school
of hard knocks the way things go the way
things ought to go
you know looking at what's socially
disapproved what's approved
even if it's not always coherent well
that is part of the the ethical
substance
and those are these customs in which one
has trust as as an individual
right each individual doesn't have to
make it
up all by themselves thank god and you
know because
you'd never get anywhere the people who
think they are going to make it up
all by themselves you got to watch out
for those those types actually
so that's the passive unchangeableness
side then it gets even more
interesting because what else does hegel
say is involved
in the ethical substance well there's a
differentiation right
organization in multiplicity
or in you know a diversity we could also
say
of different people and not just
individual people
but all sorts of factors that that are
that are coming together that are
overlapping with each other
that's part of what makes it an
organization so
he says here we go
um partly to on its organization into a
multiplicity of rights and
duties right so that's that's seemingly
applying to the
whole set of individuals not everybody
necessarily has
all the same rights or the same duties
but everybody's got some of them right
and you you have to live them out that
defines you
as an ethical person ethically good or
ethically bad
right or whatever other qualities we
want to
signify in this not only do we have
individuals with rights and duties
but we also he says uh on its
distribution into the spheres the maasan
the the
masses of the the various
classes stenda this is a very important
idea
for hegel he doesn't want a society
in the end where everybody is exactly on
you know the same level all the time he
actually does think that there's some
usefulness in having social classes with
different
functions or as it's going to be called
here
particular activities
right tunes are deeds or
actions he could use the word handle
there as well particular
comportments the things that they they
do so all of this is is a part of the
reality of ethical substance
and you know if you observe a city that
you
live within you know as morning dawns
and all this
the activities start happening you can
get some sense of that you look at a
working farm you look at
all the ways in which we administer or
fail to administer justice those are all
parts of
of this ethical substance the
storytellers that are reinforcing
or challenging moral norms or screwing
them up
you know making them superficial or
making the really important questions
come out that's all part of this
as well so he goes on and he says that
these these cooperate to form the whole
and then he says hence on the fact that
the individual is content
right so the individual we come back to
the self-consciousness
that is not withdrawn into itself and
that is
um you know it's got these these custom
and this trust going on so the
individual is content
with limitation with the shrinking
you know being closed in into something
that is being provided by
this we might call it blueprint for
how things are supposed to go in society
oh you're a carpenter
great you do some carpentry and you also
you know when it's festival time behave
in this way and you contribute a little
bit of tax to this
and like a good person when you see a
crime being report
crime happening you report the crime but
you don't take action on it necessarily
yourself
because maybe there's the city archons
the rulers that will take care of that
so the individual is content with their
own
limitation in this this sense he says
right the limitation of their existence
and they have not yet grasped the
unrestricted thought of their free self
now at any moment somebody could realize
this free self that the more ace are
kind of arbitrary they've been around
for a long time
or they've been recently you know
instituted but they're not necessarily
the best
way of doing things anybody at any point
in time could be like
wait a second this isn't this isn't
necessarily the way things have to go
but that's not happening yet at this
point
so he goes on and he says this tranquil
immediate trust in the substance turns
back into
here's work it's very interesting trust
in one's self
and into the certainty give his height
of one's own self now where did we see
this certainty of oneself
well at a number of different points the
most recent of which was
conscience right
back in the morality section and that
led into all sorts of
quandaries it wasn't quite so easy to
determine it's not like you just have
the light bulb go out of your head oh
conscience i can think of everything the
whole thing for myself i don't need all
of this baggage
well you actually do need that baggage
but
which baggage do you need you don't need
all of it necessarily
so he goes that and he says the
multiplicity of rights and duties
like the restricted activity of the
individual
is the same dialectical movement of the
ethical sphere
as the multiplicity now here no notice
what he says here
the multiplicity of things
not persons things
how did persons turn into things they
can be objectified right
or we can think of a person maybe just
in terms of their
functions and then specific
natures translate here translates here
and these apply to the things right
we could say determinations as well the
thing and its
determinations but it's not the thing
it's the whole bunch of things
we might see this as sort of like the
corollary of the personal
and class-based function-based
uh involvement of the ethical substance
here so we have a kind of
maybe materialization we could say of of
this going on
as well so we're getting a richer and
richer world
richer and richer environment for
spirit on its little trajectory here
aren't we he goes on and he says
the multiplicity of these rights and
duties is the same dialectical movement
as the multiplicity of things their
specific natures a movement which finds
its rest and stability
only in the simplicity of the spirit
that is certain of itself now
what simplicity of the spirit certain of
itself is ethical substance providing
that
no it's it now we come back to the
individual right
and we get individuality withdrawn
into itself so he says the consummation
of the ethical sphere
in free self-consciousness and
the fate of the ethical world so this is
pretty important stuff here right or
what
the individuality einsteinide
that is withdrawn into itself
here hegel uses three terms that i
really wanted to
signal because they establish a mood
or a set of interlocking moods for
what's happening
and there's kind of a duplicity going on
here which i'll signal in just a moment
so he says
um here we go
he this individuality that is withdrawn
into itself which is now spirit
the absolute levity of the ethical
sphere
spirit which is dissolved within itself
all the firmly established distinctions
of its stable existence
all the spheres of its organically
ordered world
right this levity like zinn right and
then we have
what else has attained to an
unrestrained
right not not being limited not being
confined
joyfulness feuding kite
and he says
the freest enjoyment
of itself not not just enjoyment of
you know whatever's out there to take
satisfaction in eat it up you know
uh watch some tv screw around you know
get drunk or something like that
enjoyment of itself so we have levity
joyfulness
enjoyment this is really you know if
this was
music it'd be very cheerful
triumphant major mode kind of stuff
getting it from maybe
not beethoven but mozart you know or
somebody like that
now that's that's only one side of the
story but that
we don't want to leave that out that
that is quite important
so he goes on and he says this simple
certainty of spirit within itself has a
two-fold
meaning so there's two sides to this
right it is a serene
stable existence and subtle truth on the
one hand
absolute unrest in the passing away of
the ethical
order on the other hand well that sounds
pretty bad do we want the ethical order
to pass away can it be taken up
into this this moment of enjoyment
and the individuality can can that bear
the weight of what the ethical order was
providing something that we
in fact desire we desire as
self-consciousness
i'm gonna go on a little bit of a
tangent here as self-consciousness is
we don't just desire the desire of the
other
or recognition or acknowledgement of the
other
a single person we desire
recognition acknowledgement being told
we matter
to the ethical substance and and many of
us never get that right and we often
live in societies
that are alienated and alienating
but that doesn't mean that we don't
desire it that we don't want it that
we're not seeking it even if we can't
get it
and it could also be within the scope of
smaller institutions you know
uh workplaces families all those sorts
of things as well even
maybe you know today in our online
setting online
in platforms people seeking out that
so this is uh this is a really important
turning point
he goes on and he says it changes round
into the ladder what's the latter the
passing away of the ethical order
the truth of the ethical spirit is in
the first instance
still only this substantial essence and
trust in it
in which the self does not know itself
as a free individuality
right so that's that's our starting
point that's what we're coming back to
and he says uh and which therefore in
this inwardness or the liberation of the
self perishes so it seems like
insofar as we get away from this trust
in the morris or the
you know the ethic the moral norms the
the customs
the ordering of things finding our own
place
as we break free from that through
exercising our rational
faculties and living a life practical
action we don't just have this happiness
we also have estrangement or alienation
we also have what he's going to call
here
grief or sorrow taking place as well
why because he says um
the trust is broken the substance of the
nation
bruised now who is this
who's the substance of the nation
bruised by is it just sort of some
random thing
oh it's too bad things didn't work out
no the the individuality who is
stripping themselves out of the ethical
substance
and pursuing something in addition to it
pursuing remember that
what was not in the ethical substance
this principle
of free individuality that does exist
that's out there
it shows that the ethical substance the
community does not contain the hole and
it is bruised it's it's you know damaged
it's
you know shown as insufficient as a
result but it's still there it's still
wounded it's still
you know going on just as much as
you know when you go off to wherever
you're you're going in your life as an
adolescent
and you you know could be the army could
be college could be you know moving out
and getting a job and having your own
stuff
your family's still behind you you know
and maybe they still want you to be that
that kid
who you were or maybe they're more
mature and can recognize that you're
growing up
or they're somewhere in between and
they they want something back from you
they want to
reconnect with you unless they're a
bunch of jerks
in which case maybe good riddance let's
go on he
says the trust is broken the substance
of the nation bruised
spirit which hitherto mediated the
unstable extremes what are the unstable
extremes
ethical substance individuality has now
stepped forth
as an extreme spirit is now on the side
of the self-consciousness grasping
itself
as essence and so he says this is spirit
inwardly sure of itself which mourns
over the loss of its world and now out
of the purity of self creates its own
essence which is raised above the real
world the vehicle
kite right so you know this is this is a
a passage that contains joy and
and sorrow lightness
and grief we might say to you know
paraphrase both spinoza and lev chest
off
uh laughing and weeping right although
hegel is not using
those terms here but we have these
modalities
very interesting emotional modalities
coming into play here as well
so a lot going on in this and you could
think of this as a
circular movement that's taking place
which is going to be
affecting the ethical substance now
we've gotten kind of far away from
art and from religion haven't we
in this this paragraph we've talked a
lot about ethics we've talked a lot
about
self-consciousness we've talked a lot
about rights and duties and you know
the world of things how are we going to
get back now
into talking about religion and religion
particularly in terms of the
the artwork and the artify sir now
an artist well that's coming in in
the following paragraphs
you